y ahora nos piden que simplifiquemos
esta resta de estos dos polinomios
entonces voy a volver a escribir esta
resta de polinomios deshaciéndome de
todos los paréntesis como le tenga que
hacer para deshacerme de ellos por aquí
tenemos 16 x 16 x + 14 + 14 nos
deshicimos superbien de estos dos
paréntesis porque en realidad estos dos
paréntesis no están modificando en lo
más mínimo a lo que tienen adentro no
están cambiando las operaciones entonces
simplemente pueden desaparecer ahora con
estos paréntesis tenemos que tener mucho
más cuidado porque tenemos un símbolo de
menos aquí adelante aunque hay entonces
estamos restando todos los términos que
estén adentro de este paréntesis así es
que si queremos quitar estos paréntesis
tenemos que distribuir el menos a cada
uno de los términos
entonces nos va a quedar menos
- 3x cuadrada y luego menos x menos x
porque el x está dentro del paréntesis
entonces queremos restarlo ok también
podemos pensar que quitemos sumando un
menos uno por todo el paréntesis
entonces tenemos que menos uno por 3x
cuadrada más menos 1 por x + menos 1 x
menos 9 que es nuestro siguiente término
menos por menos nos da más
entonces queda más 9 que en realidad es
un menos -9 bien entonces ya por fin nos
deshicimos de esos paréntesis y ahora
pues queremos simplificarlo entonces
vamos a agrupar todos los términos que
podamos ok para que nos quede bonito el
polinomio lo que tenemos que hacer es
empezar con los términos que tengan el
grado más grande de la variable x aunque
en este caso es x al cuadrado así es que
vamos a buscar todos los términos que
tengan x cuadrada
que pues nada más es este entonces
tenemos por aquí menos 3 x cuadrada y no
seguimos con los términos que tengan al
siguiente grado más grande de x ok como
ya terminamos con x al cuadrado entonces
nos toca buscar a los términos que
tengan x a la 1 o sea simplemente x así
es que buscamos este es uno de esos
términos éste no éste también tienen una
sola equis y éste tampoco entonces pues
vamos a sumarlos aquí tenemos más 16 x
más menos x y xi tenemos 16 de una cosa
y menos 1 de esa misma cosa entonces en
realidad tenemos 15 de esa cosa que es
equis y bueno vamos con los siguientes
términos que tengan el siguiente grado
más grande de x que aquí tenemos x a la
1 entonces lo que le sigue es x a la
cero o sea
a uno así es que estamos buscando a
todas las constantes y pues esas son
estas dos que son los términos que
sobran entonces 14 más 9 eso es 23 y
listo
hemos terminado